i am not a bad guy i am a good guy
who runs over women with his car
i'm sorry that was so good
i'm not a bad guy i'm a good guy
who runs over women with his car
i am not a bad guy i am a good guy who
runs over women with this car
why am i having such a hard time getting
my message across
[Laughter]
what are you doing here hi how are you
hi i'm not in character yet
i promise to give authority back to you
when this crisis is
do
over
say it
hey
turn your head over
i'm sorry
it
do it
hey michael
apparently this computer has been
programmed to feel human emotions
well
that's not how i'm programmed
[Music]
i'm sorry we only take mastercard or
diners club you take
come on come on here we go
ah
what are you doing here
you want to go today i can't give him
blood so
wow good for you good for you
how often can you actually donate blood
is there a limit i don't i don't thought
there was well
your body only has a certain amount
[Laughter]
can you hear me what
what
i can hear you why are you calling me my
minutes don't roll over i have to use
them today
okay there's a press release that ryan
would like
mccushla
he's watching million dollar baby
he's gonna try to kill me
uh i know i used to be a temp here and
now i'm your boss and i understand how
that must be weird for you
but yep
i'm really sorry i broke that was too
good
well i'd
do the scene but bj's not here
and resetting
20 minutes to go time 20 seconds
[Music]
these are for you oh well how thoughtful
yes
and one flower
can we start from the beginning
[Music]
that is the best flower ever okay so
we're all leaving for the hospital at
one o'clock
free entry i can take three
[Laughter]
we're leaving for the hospital at one
the freedom tree
sorry let's just go through that part
okay we're leaving for the hospital at
one like a freedom treaty
maybe you could just change the u into
an a
then it would say lance party kevin
would it really be better if it said
lance party oh hey how much party it's
supposed to say launch easy billy barty
nobody cares about this
damn i am trying to lose five pounds so
i brought in a fruit platter instead of
cake for my birthday but when michael
saw it he said that's that cake and he
threw it into the trash so i was so mad
and upset that i dug it out of the trash
and i ate the entire thing in the
women's bathroom
do you know how hard it is to eat
sorry i'm sorry i'm not professional
enough to do this i can't
michael oh hey toby could you close the
door on your way out
[Laughter]
hi holly yeah hi i'm paul
i'm toby
oh man wow
that's fantastic okay
i guess what surround sound means is
that right over here jim
[Laughter]
two speakers
damn
we have two speakers
what honey oh jesus
this is terrible
never finish this episode
um check this out
folds
oh my god
okay michael i might have someone for
you
here she's really sweet and nice you
guys might actually get along
is she hot
that was such a bad day
that was the worst take ever
are
[Laughter]
dwight
[Laughter]
dwight
[Laughter]
pam
what is wrong with me
i'm so sorry you're standing in your
closet
i walked into this
man who's standing in a closet
it's like ridiculous looking
i've actually done like six fun runs for
summer this charity
[Laughter]
i asked for assorted cutlery and i got
back spoons these are worthless
i want to understand what you're saying
but it's difficult for me when you use
that tone
why do you have to say tone like that
she goes down
i
want to understand what you're saying
but
it's difficult for me to
when you use that tone
i want to understand what you're saying
but it's difficult for me when you use
that tone
phyllis
stop it
you're hurting me i'm sorry
that's our writer if you don't deal with
things right away they only get worse
it's called appeasement
oh god
that is so disgusting
i haven't eaten cottage cheese a long
time
wow
you have 75 cents so that means you
could get anything in the top row
so that means you could get anything in
the top row
sorry
jen you're gonna have to go into another
row
what's this
a detonator what
[Music]
what
a detonator don't push me down what
what are you doing
stop it
i'm just
stop spin i'm trying to confuse your
sense of direction
[Laughter]
i am gonna bang holly
she is cute and helpful and she really
seems to be okay
i am so gonna bang holly
she is cute
i am so gonna bang holly she is cute and
helpful
don't come near me
don't do your sexy man dance you know
how i love it michael
5k means 5 kilometers you put five
thousand miles on this flyer
come in
hey oh my god
oh
yeah
no
michael stay you said come in
oh my god
so we were wondering do we now have to
sign one of those
office relationship forms
i'll print them out when you come back
later
you